[Music]
hey you guys we're back again oh and you
have your new hat on yeah yeah it's it's
the black version of his sexual
tyrannosaur exactly exactly this is this
is my new
black booney hat by rothko
i could wear this one to the club if i
wanted to do whatever wants the black
one
the other one i have is tiger stripe
yeah so you need a black one so it'll go
with the rest of your whatever i want
vor drew that's right i don't know this
[ __ ] here
has been well documented to increase
levels of toxic masculinity you put that
[ __ ] on
it's just soaking right into your ball
head right there toxic masculinity
starts to [ __ ] the toxins are just
seeping into your into your brain that's
why it's sexy
do you think that's why it's sick
all right
speaking of which
charlton heston who i don't particularly
think is sexy but you probably do no
no i i like charlton heston but uh he
was a man of his of his time
that's a nice way of putting yeah
he was kind of like a like a like a
boomer hero
boomer and beyond guys that were even
because i think he was older than a
boomer
boomer and beyond that sounds like
something that sounds like the lamest
like department store ever
yeah
he had his own way you know of doing
things
and you know
he had he had good movies for the time
you know he had stage presence people
respected him you know he was [ __ ]
playing moses and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
him and ewell brenner and he kind of
played and he kind of plays like a jesus
e-type figure in the omega man i mean
not really a jesus figure but you know
what i mean there there is a lot of
jesus he gives his life in this to save
mankind by his blood
which is that he
kind of dies in a crucifix position but
uh you know he was atoned for his sins
basically
because he caused a lot of this [ __ ]
he's all charlton heston's fault did you
hear that yeah well
it's a good movie it's a deeper it's the
it's not just a um
it's not just an action movie it has
some deeper motifs going on it's well
thought out and it you know it's based
on like in uh the book was i am legend
yeah and then loosely
loosely and then um
uh last man on earth had vincent price
which is evidently closer to the book
yes it's much closer this is the same
story it's just kind of rebooted and
they they uh
put a couple of twists in it
um if you know the other if you listen
to our other program when we did when we
covered the first movie
in that one he meets a girl who turns
out to be a spy
for
the vampires basically
and they end up killing him
this one lisa isn't a spy sh but she
used to be with the family
and when she didn't turn
she felt uncomfortable in there because
she her and her little brother richie
they didn't look like the the family
they didn't go albino
so they were real
started to get real suspicious of them
so they snuck out
of the family so she was
ex-family they were infected
and they she eventually did flip and she
went back to the family but she wasn't a
spy
and he ended up saving her too
um but it's just a good flip good flick
it has a lot of good motifs
the idea here is um
charlton heston plays neville
and he was an army
colonel who worked at the bio warfare
division
and the unit that he was working with
i don't think they made this weapon i
think it was between the chinese and the
russians that made it wasn't it yeah
yeah there was a war between the that
was the thing and that was another thing
they changed a lot from the book in the
book they kind of like it's implied that
it was just like a natural like virus
that came from bats or something like
that whereas in this one it was very
deliberate it was uh germ warfare but
that kind of like went along more with
like movies of this period because i
feel like late 60s early 70s you had
kind of all those cold wars like
paranoid type thrillers uh so this was
kind of like an early example of that
where they made it like someone's fault
like somebody humans did it on purpose
well they they're this this movie is
definitely from the cold
war and uh the nuclear annihilation you
know the mutually assured destruction
was a played out theme already
and you couldn't have this story
in in a nuclear with
amongst a nuclear backdrop it could only
work if it was bio warfare so that's
what they went with well and the woman
the woman that co-wrote the screenplay
uh it's a husband and wife team
that did it uh the woman that co-wrote
the screenplay was uh had a phd in
chemistry
and so she's like around this time
period you know like i said when paranor
paranoia was kind of rising and she was
thinking a lot about germ warfare and
she's like maybe we should inject like
the germ warfare thing because that
would like wipe out a bunch of people at
the same time like i said the the book
was kind of more
it didn't go that much into it it
implied that it was just like a natural
virus because it was more interested in
exploring um you know the the loneliness
and the sort of like inversion of like
the hero villain roles you know what i'm
saying like that's more what the book
was about than like the scientific kind
of stuff now that book and the first
movie that came from it
um uh is is really the genesis of
[ __ ] the zombie apocalypse concept
because um
uh night of the living dead was is a
ripoff of the first movie of this is
definitely when you see it what's it
called last man on earth when you see
last man on earth you see where romero
got all those ideas all right
they're they're both good movies
night of living dead it's probably a
little bit better
but um
last man on earth is a lot more
complicated
denied a living dead
the the scope's bigger
this is just a retelling of last man on
earth it's the same story it's just that
the order and certain things are
different and the backdrop's a little
bit different it's it was updated to to
make more sense to say like in what 72
or 71
71 right well the whole thing about the
family and this one that's like a
complete movie invention um the book
isn't it's not really like that
the like i said in the book they're just
vampires and they're kind of like
vampires but sort of like zombie-like
they can kind of talk but they're not
real
eloquent or they're they don't have
their they didn't form a cult or
anything like that
um you know what i mean so
this is kind of like well they got that
from the movie they got the move from
last man on earth
remember that yeah remember the the half
vampire
yeah yeah yeah i know yeah italian
fascist
mussolini black shirts
it's those guys it's just that they've
been rebooted as kind of like a like a
medieval like luddite monks or something
yeah medieval
satanic cult that's kind of based on
like that extinction rebellion type of
mentality to where
you know [ __ ] uh um we gotta stop all
technology and science and
you know they're trying to go back to
like
pre-industrial era
and it's like tokamada and the
inquisition which i thought was great
now my friend my friend [ __ ] khan of
otsulon down in mexico he he thought it
was goofy he thought it looked like the
jawas
i didn't really get that because it
predates jawas i saw this before i ever
saw star wars
and uh so i didn't make that that
connection
and uh you know
having a strong european background you
immediately see that as religious monks
you know
yeah
clearly they're supposed to be monks
yeah because they have i mean they have
like the black monk robes and they're
very they you know they're they're very
kind of like
some modest areas yeah like yeah
monastic yeah and they don't like
anything
technology technological they don't want
anything like that they're in they've
taken over city hall and they've moved
all this damn religious paraphernalia
into city hall and it's just like this
baroque damn satanic and they burn
people at this point
yeah you know stuff like that so and
they kind of meet up in a big old
[ __ ] chapel it's not a chapel it's a
courtroom but it's got
i remember seeing wasn't didn't they
have like certain things upside down so
it looked like upside down crosses the
wood panelings i thought i saw some
things like that well i didn't notice
that but yeah i mean how wood paneling
sometimes headed like a cross and i
thought it looked like they were upside
down i thought they had one of them
painted or something but i'd have to go
back and look at it might have just
been how i remembered it but it's just
kind of has and like the font of the
movie when it starts with the omega man
i want to make it a mega man shirt in
the omega man because i told him i was
like hey i have that yeah yeah yeah
that's going to save the olympic theater
and i'm probably going to have that
[ __ ] smith and wesson mk 760
underneath it or something something
that's
you know that's not not a photo hest on
it you know i mean just something that's
more like uh geometric that would look
good like in a club setting but i won't
always get a shirt like that
but um
it's just uh
the the main theme here is uh neville
when he was with his bio unit
and the [ __ ] plague started to hit
america they were working on a cure
they had an experimental batch but it
was coming too late people were already
dying
and he was trying to deliver the [ __ ]
experimental batch and he was in a
helicopter helicopter crashed
and he crawled out of the wreckage and
found the damn
briefcase of [ __ ]
experimental vaccine and he took it
and he turned out that he lived he
didn't ever did get infected
um so he was the only man that was
really immune to it
he thinks he's alone
you know turns out there's these damn
people that survived it that kind of
mutated they turned into these
psychopathic albinos
that suffered from what is it bouts of
toppoor
torpor and what else did they do they
did just
light
sensitivity
they couldn't they were blind in the
light um
it would and the light would just drive
them up the wall
they didn't say anything about blood
drinking they just said yeah they
weren't vampires and they weren't dead
people no they were like so that's like
that's another kind of thing that's
different from the book and also from
the original adaptation is that like i
said in the book it's pretty clear that
they're vampires i mean they're
essentially vampires um and in the movie
they're pretty much vampires yeah um you
know you can have the disease and still
be alive but usually they're kind of
dead and then they come back to life
whereas in this one it seems like
they're just alive they're just mutated
humans
that they don't have any vampiric
tendencies other than
being light sensitive yeah and
everybody's pretty much it pretty much
everybody else is dead yeah it killed
you
it normally just killed you on the spot
as soon as you caught it but these
people got mutated
and um over time they kind of
became like this cult this this kind of
like something like cross between
extinction rebellion and antifa type of
deal and the in tokamada all kind of
mashed together they kind of speak kind
of like in marxist kind of terminology
in a certain way you just got to watch
the movie it's well thought out
and they find out about neville that
neville never turned he never got the
sores and never turned so they hated him
they blamed him for it
because they kind of they knew he was
deciding well they're like you're the
last relic of the past and the past that
that caused the world to come to this
yeah and they're trying to erase him
because they're trying to erase he they
say he's obsolete and he's got to go
so neville
he's in his house that he
had lived in you know uh in l.a before
the the disaster even happened and he's
like they're not gonna push me out of my
house you know i'm staying right here
and he's turned into a dad all my cool
shit's there yeah
he brings even more cool all of my
scotch i have like years and years worth
of scotch in there
[Laughter]
which is probably what i mean he's got
the whole place rigged up man with a
[ __ ] elevator that can he can shut
off and [ __ ] security gates and flood
lights and generators of fuel and in the
bottom he's got
jeeps military jeeps and [ __ ]
motorcycles and sports cars and all his
[ __ ] you know what i mean and upstairs
he's got a laboratory and a bedroom the
kitchen and it all looks like a damn
museum because he's getting all the good
[ __ ] from all around the city yeah he
goes to museums like yeah swipes all the
art got all kinds of classic sub machine
guns mp40s [ __ ] smithson's wesson mk
760s he's got a [ __ ] bar where the
[ __ ] active [ __ ] ir [ __ ] knight
scope on it he's got all kinds of cool
[ __ ] he's got a [ __ ] bar he got no
he's got two
two m250 bell-fed guns on the [ __ ]
roof sandbags i mean it's a [ __ ]
castle
and every day those damn mutants come
out there and start trolling him neville
neville come out neville like kind of
[ __ ] you know and he's like oh [ __ ] he's
trying to play chess with himself he's
going crazy because he by himself
yeah so slash your friend's like there's
no phone ringing damn
[Laughter]
it's classic memes in this [ __ ] movie
man i mean not quite as good as you know
get your hands off me damn dirty yeah
yeah but close close or you blew it up
there's a lot of that [ __ ] damn you oh
then he like uh
every day he's gotta [ __ ] drive them
off and they won't use any technology
because it's against their religion you
know the economy he's a user of the
wheel and all that kind of [ __ ] you know
like i said it's almost like luddites
you know what luddites are right like a
long time ago well now the word means
pretty much anybody that's like doesn't
like new technology or it's like scared
of new technology but it came from i
can't remember what year it was it's
like a few centuries ago i think but it
was this group of people who
were like uh
weavers i think or tailors or something
like that and when everything like when
the industrial revolution happened and
all these machines came in they would go
around like busting all the machines
because it was like taking all their
work away so they were like really
really into not
using any machines or technology yeah
so he spends two years
fighting these guys
three years i think is it at least two
or three it's two or three years i can't
remember and he can't figure out where
they live
so he's doing searches grid searches
every day
trying to figure out where their nest is
he's just on this damn campaign and
[ __ ] annihilating them
and he just they show a lot of scenes
where he's going through little hotels
looking for him and he'll find a dead
one every now and then
um sometimes he'll just see one of them
running he'll shoot at him with sub gun
real good [ __ ] sub machine gun real
good sub machine gun scenes you know
um
there's there's one that he uses [ __ ]
quite a bit
and he has a dive light underneath of it
underneath it that's looking detachable
and for
gun guys know what it is but a few
non-gun people i'll tell you why they're
using that
movie shot in 71.
back in the late 60s when when the u.s
army was [ __ ] around in vietnam we
weren't officially supposed to be there
so they were taking special forces guys
and dressing them up like international
mercenaries and sending them in there
to do [ __ ] okay
but it was illegal
you couldn't give them american weapons
so they were buying the [ __ ] swedish
k which was a good sub machine gun made
in sweden sweden found out what we were
doing says we're not going to sell you
one of those sub machine guns so smith
and wesson made a kind of a copy of it
was improved a little bit called mk 760
smith wesson
so they're using that gun in the movie
because there's kind of it's kind of
symbolic in the gun scene at that time
that's a special forces [ __ ] kind of
commando submachine gun it had a certain
mystique to it it was good it was a good
submachine gun
kind of like a nine millimeter like
improved [ __ ] grease gun but better
like a swedish cake
so he's using that thing
to just try to hunt him down and there's
just a lot of good scenes
of him with that gun i liked it
um
let's see what else can i say about it
the
the theme here is is that
he could have left the city
all right but he didn't he stayed
to fight these things
and there's kind of a kind of a deep
reason why
before the war he was
a scientist and a military man
who was dedicated to
he's the kind of guy that defended his
civilization with force
well the civilization shrank down to
just him and his house
so that's what he's doing
if he wasn't fighting them he wouldn't
have a purpose he just would have been
alone totally alone so it was better to
stay there and fight for what he
believed in instead of just running out
and being insignificant and dying in
obscurity in absolute
solitude
because at least if you're fighting an
enemy you're not alone
so that's what's happening here
well one day he finds out that there's
another group
besides these these mutants there's
other people that are infected that
never flipped so he falls in with them
and uh
it's an it's like another crowd
it's a it's a biker guy
with a chopper
who dropped out of was forced out of med
school in his senior year because the
[ __ ] civilization collapsed
and then
his right-hand man is this uh
black chick who's like an ex-black
panther
and they're taking care of all these
kids that they've yeah and she has a
little brother named brother dude
who's turned who's turning yeah
and neville says you know my blood is a
serum i could probably save him he saves
richie
and you know she thinks this is great
and they start having like a
relationship because she wasn't having a
relationship with with the bike or guy
even though they were about the same
size same age i'm guessing he was having
a relationship with one of those girls
in the late teens that was with him but
they didn't really
they didn't really get into that because
remember some girls must spend 17 18 19.
what would you say yeah i can't remember
there was just like a bunch of it was
just like a bunch of so you don't really
know why they weren't hooked up but she
hooks up with neville
when richie gets better
he tries to talk sense into neville
he's like you know you're wiping out all
these
people and they're infected they're
they're just regular people yeah they're
just sick people right they're just sick
you should try to help them once you go
down and help them and give them some of
your blood and you'll make and he goes
nah they'll never work you know they're
vermin basically so richie gets kind of
like high-minded and
i guess altruistic altruistic and he
goes down there
he tells neville where they were [ __ ]
nesting up they were they were living in
city hall
and devil's like really
well neville finds out that he's [ __ ]
missing and he's where'd he go [ __ ]
richie went down there to go talk to the
damn
family the zombies not the zombies with
the uh the the mutants
and richie shows up [ __ ] goes you
know
neville his blood can heal you we can go
back to like you were before and we'll
be okay and he's like we were before
that's the [ __ ] the guy who's running it
you know matthias matthias is the cult
leader he's badass he's good
he's a really good character and in the
movie before the apocalypse hit he was a
newscaster yeah so he had good oratory
skills and people recognized him off a
television so that he became the leader
and matthias was like oh like we were
before yeah okay [ __ ] that's kind of
our whole thing
and they didn't want to hear that
yeah
so they [ __ ] they strung little
richie up and did something bad to him
you just see blood coming out of his
mouth you don't know exactly i was under
the impression that they stabbed him to
death
i think didn't they have him wasn't he
kind of crucified with a bunch of spikes
something like that you couldn't really
tell because they mostly just showed
like his face yeah they must have wanted
to shadow it out it's kind of in the
shadows they don't want to be too
graphic because it's a kid he's maybe
what 12
something like that yeah remember when i
was a little kid and saw that on
television that blew my mind that was
the first time i ever saw a movie where
a kid got killed in it yeah that's whoa
really i'm still actually kind of
surprised that they went there yeah but
well neville was on his way down there
he [ __ ] suited up he put his [ __ ]
commando [ __ ] blue air force fight
flight suit on and his [ __ ] colonel
hat and his [ __ ] guns and jumps in
the damn
jeep and [ __ ] fights his way
through the damn hordes to try to get
richie but he was already dead when he
found him
and uh he was on his way out and as he
was on his way out he runs into lisa and
lisa had turned
yeah because they said they established
early that
so you could just turn like without
warning you know like sometimes it was
really slow but sometimes it would just
like come on you really quick when they
turn they kind of become communal they
kind of become kind of like a [ __ ]
group or hive mind in some ways you say
the family's calling me you know
so i guess there's kind of like uh
they're talking about uh how you become
kind of like in today's terminology
become like an npc it's like group think
so she starts getting grouped but you're
evil robert you know
i was kind of thinking because they were
called the family i didn't know if they
were making a specific reference to like
the manson family or
there was that cult i think we did a
show about that that was called the
family yeah
so they're talking about like any of
those kind of cults from that time where
everybody's just kind of like gets
thinking and [ __ ] there's not a lot
of individuality you know that's that's
that's what they're talking about
and uh but he grabs her anyway and kind
of saves her but he gets killed in the
big shootout
and then uh next he gets speared he gets
speared yeah
now they had mathias had a right hand
right hand man
name was oh well i guess that he got
keep zach zachary got killed before yeah
though zachary was already dead winning
yeah he got um he got killed trying to
get in through the damn yeah charlton
heston like either shot him or like
threw him like out the window and he
fell down the balcony and like fell on
the fence remember yeah he shot him up
with a [ __ ] mp40 yeah
and uh there's a lot of good a lot of
good machine gun scenes in it
uh
so he ended up basically saving the
survivors by his own blood they got him
[ __ ] laying out there yeah it's very
cheesy like a [ __ ] right well i mean
there's even more references to that
because when um
when lisa first meets him and like
doesn't know what his deal is exactly
she's like got a gun on him and she's
like put your hands out and she's like
put your hands out like you're like
we're crucifying you or something like
that so that's
foreshadowing there's a bunch of
references to like neville being duelist
he's a soldier and a scientist
like she talks about his [ __ ] she
mentions his uh laboratory and he goes
like well yeah i got to keep the other
side active he's talking about the other
side of himself the science side yeah
you know so it's got a lot of cool like
uh
um [ __ ]
psychology in it
kind of deeper messages
i like it real good movie classic now
i want to see the uh i want to see the
last man on earth again
i think i look
i think every time i watch these movies
i appreciate it more i pick up more i
see little things in the background
stuff stuff in in the set
you know certain things happen and you
can kind of see there's like a little
subplot or a sub story
it's just good movies good writing
slasher fred said there was a simpsons
halloween episode where in one of the
segments was a spoof of the omega man
called the omega man
i think i might have seen that actually
because of homer you know my only uh uh
criticism of the omega man
is uh you know i'm looking at
for a movie of its time
the incidental music in the soundtrack
in the in the first part of the movie
doesn't fit the tone it's too it's not
dark enough
and there's certain yeah it should just
be silence
but still they got to put some kind of i
mean this is very much like an action
movie but it does seem like that rather
than a horror movie because it's not
scary
but the thing was when it was when you
were a kid i mean when you're a kid yeah
but i don't think it and i don't even
think it was really trying to be scary
particularly i think it was supposed to
be more like an action movie like a
post-apocalyptic action movie and yeah i
kind of feel like the score at the
beginning was kind of more like
but i get that was like a problem with a
lot of scores from the 70s though they
all sounded to me it all sounded like uh
you know like cheesy nighttime soaps
from the 1970s like it all kind of
sounded like that danny rowling said in
all seriousness no way in hell he would
have survived that helicopter crash in
my opinion yeah that was a pretty bad
crash you know what's crazy i found this
out today while i was researching this
movie the guy that directed this movie
uh boris seagal who was uh um the
ukrainian-born dude
and he would mostly did tv i think he
did like a handful of movies including
this one but he mostly did tv like
twilight zone alfred hitchcock presents
night gallery man from on coal [ __ ] like
that but speaking of helicopters in 1981
the same director
was working on this mini-series called
world war three
and he got killed
when
he walked into the rotor blades
of a helicopter and like got partially
decapitated that was like in 1981 isn't
that [ __ ] crazy i was just like oh my
god it was just kind of like [ __ ]
twilight zone people have mentioned some
funny stuff about this movie yeah people
had yellow teeth back then including
heston because they all [ __ ] smoked
yeah and they didn't do anything about
it they didn't they didn't notice it
well they didn't have the same also they
didn't have like the same kind of like
teeth bleaching stuff like now it's
really easy to do not back then
uh another thing that was mentioned in
there was uh the stunts being practical
including the motorcycle stunts yeah
they were good motorcycle stunts i mean
a lot of them you could tell that they
were it was stunt doubles obviously
on the back yeah another one too because
you could see like the wigs and whatnot
but they were taking pretty old school
motorcycles like you know [ __ ] yamaha
[ __ ] 450 twins and [ __ ] [ __ ]
running them down stairs
it's a not an easy task with those old
[ __ ] up suspensions that those they
could have been a stock suspension i
don't think well maybe it was
maybe just sped up a little bit riding
downstairs or upstairs on any motorcycle
is [ __ ] rough especially if the
wheels are too small going down of
course is always easier but to go up you
got to have a big front wheel
um
yeah and then the car stunts too
they're you know [ __ ]
all practical all practical
it's a good flick um daddy rolling a lot
of fire a lot of fire stunts yeah
setting dudes on fire
danny rowling said uh charlton heston
kissing a black woman back then was kind
of a big deal it was i think um this was
actually maybe i don't think it was the
first because i mean star trek had done
it prior
but that was tv i think this was like
the first either the first film or the
first like mainstream hollywood film
to show like an interracial kiss so yeah
that was a really big deal and that's
the thing like i don't think in the book
i haven't read the book in a while i
should probably reread it and like do um
a review on it just because i've read it
a bunch of times but it's been like
several years since i've read it and i
don't really think anything was
mentioned about it in there but they
wanted to like the screenwriters wanted
to make her a black woman because of the
black power movement and they just
thought that was like a good thing to
like insert into the movie and they
thought that would be like another
source of maybe like potential conflict
and tension like between the two
characters because they made them they
made them opposites got one of the white
military officer that one's a black
panther yeah so they were kind of like
the opposite yeah one was establishment
the other one was more revolutionary
although the weird thing is like they
didn't really i mean she said that but
they didn't really have a lot of
conflict per se it's like they kind of
met and they were just kind of like hey
who are you and then they're like oh
okay i love you you know she knocks him
out well that's true with the [ __ ]
pistol and [ __ ] you know if i can use
this [ __ ] archaic [ __ ] job
you cool it no
but the thing about it is that
well you you know why because the thing
about it and they don't go as much into
this as they did in the book and the
like the last man on earth is that
everybody knew
who neville was he was a legend like and
everybody was afraid of him because like
i said he was like that was kind of the
whole point of the book is that he was
this like mythical monster running
around in the minds of yeah so everyone
was like terrified of him and they did
go into that and the last man on earth
like one of the last things that vincent
writes price says after he gets speared
is they were afraid of me they were and
he was like regretful like i didn't know
like i didn't realize that ever that i
was the monster to them and he you know
he thought he was a hero in his own mind
this whole time like wiping out the
vampires but actually he was the monster
so that's kind of like they so they went
more into that they didn't really go
so much into that they do kind of like
mention in this that
neville is they know who he is and that
they're kind of like afraid of him
it doesn't seem like the um
like the mutants are afraid of him they
just hate him they just hate him yeah
but it does kind of come up that like
with lisa and dutch in them that it's
like oh yeah we heard about you or
everyone's kind of afraid of you because
you had like you know a reputation they
couldn't go down to the city and get
anything during the day because he was
running around shooting the place up
yeah yeah they did say that because
they're like well yeah we didn't know
like we thought we'd get shot so and
that was the first like when lisa was in
the department store and that's where he
meets her like the first time she's like
oh [ __ ] like there he is so she's like
pretend to be a mannequin and stuff
because yeah she doesn't know if he's
gonna shoot her or something like that
so she's just like what's the biker's
name dutch dutch that's right yeah dutch
it's like what are you doing down the
city where you run around [ __ ] some
kind of exterminator you know what why
why is that he goes oh they're not
chasing me out of my home he's like yeah
okay
because they could have just left like
they did they had a nice quiet place out
in the country
yeah and they didn't really seem old
yeah they didn't really seem all that
bothered by
right but he was he was just setting his
ways well like i said [ __ ]
his his his [ __ ] mindset was to have
a mission you know yes to protect
civilization
from outsiders and civilization shrunk
down to his house
so that's that's the last of the
civilization he's going to keep it he's
going to keep it just like it would but
he had that [ __ ] decked out it's [ __ ]
this movie is like a real good like
survivalist [ __ ] porn you know
look at what he's got in the house and
you go like oh yeah i'd have that oh
yeah yeah i'd have that i think that's
probably my favorite thing about this
movie is that i just love the idea like
i'm not saying i wish everybody on earth
would die i'm just saying that and i
think well i think this is appeal for a
lot of kind of like apocalypse style
movies for people it's like man i could
just wander around and i could have
anything i wanted they got these you
know
you might just take it i keep up with
you know [ __ ] prepping and [ __ ]
survivalist stuff and blah blah blah and
they got dudes talking about gonna have
their [ __ ] bug out bag
you're not gonna [ __ ] bug out you're
gonna bug in
okay and that's what neville did you're
gonna stay home
and in other countries if they [ __ ]
blow up and start [ __ ] apart [ __ ]
people don't leave their own home they
stay right in them even if it's even if
it's a
an apartment they rented they tend to
stay right there
and um because it's more dangerous to
leave
or you can't leave
like uh
which is some
like the stand it's covered in the
series the standard the book the stand
there would be no way to get a car out
of a city because all the [ __ ]
freeways were where there's a frozen
traffic jam for [ __ ] 60 miles of just
empty cars
that's
so there'd be no way to drive out of it
so you could you'd have to stay there
oh i appreciate uh linwood bringing this
up because this is something that i
wanted to mention because there is
actually a deleted scene from this movie
oh there is um yeah he says something
like uh
she became pregnant that's why the trip
to the pharmacy yeah well because i
remember saying
i'll tell you in a second but because i
remember saying wait wait in 1971 could
you just buy birth control pills like
off the shelf over the counter because
i don't like i never was able to do that
you had to get a prescription and go to
the pharmacy you couldn't just like buy
but it didn't show her like getting from
that from behind the pharmacy counter
but but what i was gonna say was that
the um
the deleted scene
they mentioned that she was pregnant
i think and she goes down into this kind
of like crypt type area and there's one
of the family down there who's like a
woman like a mother that has a baby yeah
and so she gets like really upset about
it because she's like oh [ __ ] like she
sees them as people i guess right and so
i remember seeing that so she comes back
out and she tells neville about it and
he says did you take care of it like did
you kill them and she was like no
you know what i mean because she like
saw herself as
that and then he kind of like oh yeah
okay i get what you're saying yeah i
mean when she finally turned she looked
really cool too because she had white
hair white afro and she went white and
she had that black clip look a girl
would see at the golf club
did she yeah yeah it's like something
you see the golf club with the white
contacts and stuff
um
another thing that i could probably
criticize about the movie
it kind of
goes against the i am legend theme that
should have been there
when neville's doing his grid
zone searches in the beginning
he mostly finds empty stuff empty
buildings and mostly just gets close and
[ __ ] when he does find
uh a mutant
it's it's either already dead
or it's just a shadow he shoots at
that's not so much extermination that's
more like defending yourself because he
gets jumped by him too and defends
himself and kills some of them
there should have been some scenes where
to show him the way he really was or
portrayed out of the book where he'd run
up on them while they were asleep and
machine gun them yeah exterminating them
well he staked them instead way in the
book he did yeah but in this in an omega
man he would have just run up into a
machine gun them
why they will see i think they should
have done yeah but see i think the thing
about it was that they kind of went like
i said thematically they went in a
little bit of a different direction
where they made charlton heston more of
a hero yeah more so and more likable so
like if you showed him like shooting
people like defenseless people yeah then
everybody'd be like i don't think i like
this he knows what they should have done
no yeah like i said that's a better move
that goes more with the theme of the
thing because it was supposed to be
dualism yeah you know where he was a
hero in his own mind and he was killing
monsters
but he wasn't fighting fair but neither
were they
yeah i mean and yeah and he was
he was a legend and a monster to them so
he had to be doing monstrous [ __ ] yeah
you know i mean which i think i would
have liked that in the movie they should
have darkened his character a little bit
in that aspect but and then it would
have justified why everybody was afraid
of him
yeah and why even humans were afraid of
him who hadn't turned
that you know look he would just he'd
machine gun people infected people while
they were asleep
yeah now he did try it does show a scene
where he tried to save an effective
person he
grabbed some dude he's in his [ __ ]
robe and [ __ ]
hauls him back to his [ __ ]
garage and gets him up beats on him and
[ __ ] tries to restrain him he gets
him up in the laboratory and starts
injecting him with stuff he's like
experimenting experimenting on him but
it didn't work he said he died badly he
never did show what happened he just
told the other guy he did he did die he
died badly you see i tried to save him
but
so i guess they just said
i'm not just what i don't think i could
take from it is that whatever he
injected with [ __ ] got him real sick
and he died that's what it is yeah
and that's the thing and that seemed
like really
yeah he was trying to save that person
but he was also just like trying to
experiment with an experiment so he just
like grabbed him and said you know i'm
trying to find so he was kind of trying
to save everybody by just grabbing a
random person but like i said
unlike in the book and in the original
movie
these are not
undead they're they're people they're
just like sick people yeah
they're mutants
sick mutants their [ __ ] psychopaths
with [ __ ] weird delusions and uh
states of torpor
and uh
albinoism and sunlight to drive them up
a wall
you couldn't reason with them though
you know well the ones that you tried to
reason with the ones that were too far
gone yeah but like yeah like i said the
ironic thing was that if they had just
listened for a second like they would
have gone back to their regular selves
but at that point they were too far gone
and they didn't want they want to yeah
back to their regular selves it's just
well like i said it's kind of like you'd
have to go in there and like deprogram
all of them just like you would somebody
that was in a cult like before you could
get them to like take the blood even
well i think when the virus is gone
though they i think when the virus is
gone they went kind of way back to
normal that's yeah that's how well
richie did you're rich he did because he
hadn't completely turned but he had gone
like kind of albino and his eyes were
white and he's like he couldn't like
look at light and [ __ ] like that but he
wasn't full-on yeah you know richie
tried to convince him to go down there
and go go cure them all with his blood
and he's like nah basically basically
neville goes nah [ __ ] him they're vermin
so
once you crossed once you crossed
neville he wasn't going to forgive you
and then but then he was good he goes
why don't you go down there and just
machine gun them all then don't just let
him stay like that either kill him or
cure him and he's like
nah [ __ ] him they're all dead anyway
they'll eventually die yeah that's what
he said because i mean basically that's
what the kid said he's like well if
you're not going to cure him then just
go down wipe them out then he didn't
want to risk himself
yeah he didn't do it and then later when
they caught him they said [ __ ] they
were saying we're going to build
something you know or listen
the things that we need that's what
[ __ ] matthias said [ __ ] you're
going to need a lot of coffins i
remember you [ __ ] with them because
you said they were all dying
yeah because i mean they didn't really
go into that like does i'm assuming that
the virus would eventually kill you yeah
they had them sores on them
yeah so i but i don't really know what
the timeline on that was well they were
only about three years they were like
that yeah so less than a decade baby
yeah
it's uh yeah i was like it's weird
because i've seen this movie so many
times and like every actor that's in it
i'm always kind of like
oh man i know them from this that and
the other thing so i had to look up like
every single like main actor that was in
this like just to see where i was like
recognizing them from because i couldn't
remember
sadly like rosalind cash the woman that
played uh lisa
she actually died quite a long time ago
she died in 1995.
i recognized her because i knew i had
seen her in some stuff she was on
good times remember that show yeah and
what's happening i used to watch that
with my grandma she was on night riders
she was on general hospital she was in
clute which zach is always trying to is
bugging us to uh
to reveal which we will get around to
some one of these days um she was in
tales from the hood that was like only a
year or two before she died i think
and let me see what else and we were
trying to figure out like richie because
i'd seen him in a bunch of [ __ ] too
um that actor's name is eric uh
lenouville
and i think he started out like on
sanford and son like he was on a few
episodes of that i think he was from
screen back of the screen no he wasn't
um he was in he actually probably one of
his best known roles was he was on that
show st elsewhere you remember that he
was on that for a long time he was in
black belt jones he was in death wish
yeah yeah love it first bite a force of
one that chuck norris
and then like after that like in the 80s
he actually went he's still in a movie
every now and then but he actually went
into directing okay so he's actually
directed a [ __ ] ton of tv like um ellie
law quantum leap doogie howser nypd blue
er monk gilmore girls so yeah he's done
like a [ __ ] ton of stuff he still acts
every now and then said this was his
first acting job and he had a scene with
charlton heston he said it was blowing
his mind
[Laughter]
yeah yeah pretty much yeah and i wanted
to look up paul coslow too he was the
guy that played dutch and they had a
little bit because we have this on uh
dvd and it has like a little
introduction where they have like a
couple of the actors like talking about
it
and paul he's dead now actually paul
koslow he died a couple years ago in
2019 now he was a german
because i thought like he sounded kind
of american in this but then like every
now and then like his accent was just
like
i was like i wonder where that's from
he's german that's why he looked totally
different when he got older he did
recognize him he was in vanishing point
he was in mr majestic which i just
reviewed not too long ago he was in
rooster cogburn that was that john wayne
movie i remember i remember mr majestic
yeah and i mentioned it i said that's a
dude from omega man yeah and he was on a
[ __ ] out of tv too he was on the
incredible hulk and rockford files and
quincy and tj hooker and a team and all
that kind of see that this time i
realized what a cool character dutch was
yeah i liked him a lot of cool
characters i liked him a lot in this
yeah
and um
it's a cool bike that he's on an old
chopper he had a [ __ ] thompson sub
machine gun strapped to the back of it
he had a couple of [ __ ]
cult single action army 45s [ __ ]
cross draw holsters and [ __ ]
[ __ ] biker boots
and then a
world war one aviator hat wasn't that a
world war one aviator hat i think or
something like that i think it was yeah
something like that
throwing bombs he's making bombs and
[ __ ] called it a mad bomber
yeah [ __ ] blowing [ __ ] up
um
and he was a
scientist
it was a good uh character at the and
the way when you looked at him he looked
like a real young david carradine from
like kung fu
kind of remind me of that yeah
yeah and then uh the guy that played
zachary yeah i knew i had seen him
before uh he actually died in 2004. he
was also in soylent green yeah i also
had charlton yeah
which we've been waiting is honky
paradise yeah he called yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's what it was
up there in his honky paradise that's
what that's really funny he should have
made like charlton heston should have
made a sign like over the door that said
yeah it should have been on the welcome
mat welcome
[Laughter]
but yeah so
we i think we watched soylent green not
too long ago but i don't think we ever
did a review on it yeah okay see zach
zachary brother zachary is what they
called him he was like uh he was like he
was like matthias's right-hand man like
his uh his his chief lieutenant
and he was getting pissed he's like why
don't you let me go down to the national
guard army and i'll pull and i'll bring
out a howitzer and i'll blow him right
out of his hockey paradise and he's like
no no no we're not going to do it that
way so he's making him do it with a damn
catapult shooting [ __ ] and they were
flaming [ __ ] round things
flaming balls but then later but then
later on like when they actually were
doing like the siege on his apartment
they were starting to use well that was
just zachary yeah exactly
[ __ ] it i'm just gonna use the same [ __ ]
you're fighting fire with fire yeah he
crept up the side of the [ __ ]
building he he wasn't going for matthias
[ __ ] he's like we're gonna get this
[ __ ] over with he climbed up the side in
his robe and [ __ ] and pulled out a
[ __ ] 1911 45 pistol but came in and
he got into a struggle
and [ __ ] lisa was there
and um
uh
[ __ ] neville pulled out
he had a [ __ ] german mp47 machine gun
him away and [ __ ] he went flying off
the
balcony and [ __ ] landed on the
wrought iron fence got him
it was it was that was a cool character
too though he was the
[ __ ] zachary was the only um he was
the only mutant that had any sense
he was like let's just blow him up
we got that national guard on
relationships
you know he's like he's the last user of
the wheel yeah yeah his last guy had any
sense
yeah
clearly dude says pookie treats are made
out of people
oh my god
um
uh 789 tundra says love how hess new the
last knew the lines of the movie about
woodstock nope they don't make them like
that anymore yeah he must have gone in
there although i will say like i guess
he would just go in there and show it
like whenever because that was the movie
that happened to be left in the theater
was there yeah and so he'd watch it over
and over but the funny scene near the
beginning where he goes in there and he
watches it and then he comes out and
he's like oh [ __ ] it's almost dark i'm
like yeah that's how sunset works bro
it's like you'd think that after three
years
he would have his [ __ ] together enough
to be like hey don't want to sit in the
movie theater all day and i was slipping
and then come out i guess
yeah maybe i guess they were trying to
like imply that he was going crazy kind
of loose remember he runs out and then
he goes [ __ ] here's the phone's
ringing and all the phones in the city
and he goes there is no phone damn it
there is no phone
and it stopped and he's like okay
stop that [ __ ] that's what i thought
yeah there's no phone god damn it brain
yeah
i know how he feels
wait you hear you hear me bring it up
it's just your imagination so every time
you get like really mad or frustrated
you're just gonna go there
yeah that's right there is no phone
ringing damn it
there is no phone
[Laughter]
i make a great shirt
everybody be like what the [ __ ] is it
don't worry about it
lynnwood slices damn hutch past wow
thank you jenny wasn't aware of that sad
news i wasn't either because like i said
we had the dvd and they had there was a
little bit of a introduction on there
that had him and had the guy that played
richie and they were talking and he
looked like you know old but i was just
kind of like well it's possible he could
still be alive but khan jumps in there
making fun of javas they were not job
was we were taught we recovered that
[ __ ] man i will that was pokemon man and
the monks i will here's the thing though
i kind of wish
that the robes i don't have a problem
with the robes i just kind of wish the
robes looked more like monks robes that
were like um
like more matte because they look kind
of like shiny some were they were all
different yeah i think they made them
i don't i think they made the amount of
things that they found because a couple
of them were brown
other ones other ones were matte and
some of them were shiny with shiny
stripes in them just like that's what i
was thinking it was like those were
those were the fabulous memories of the
family they were just kind of like all i
had was this like shiny material i think
it was just blackout curtains that they
found and [ __ ] that they found and were
making it they weren't factory made
they were making them well yeah but
it's just i thought that was kind of
funny well it just makes i guess it made
them like seem a little less menacing
i'm gonna be less menaced by
a mutant in a shiny cloak than i am in
one that's like a regular monkey well i
think that was uh that was that was
brother zachary that had the one that
was [ __ ] shiny
he's like i gotta have some style these
didn't have sequins on it yeah
most of them looked pretty good
especially when they were off in the
darkness
rhinestone rose on the back here's some
[ __ ] remember that one shot though when
they're they're doing the trial and
someone back then it looks like their
eyes are glowing
it was actually the reflection of the
sunglasses but it looked like yeah
because they all wore sunglasses even in
the dark
they wear their sunglasses at night just
like cory hart well they were they were
blind yeah they were blind with
blind in the light i did like those
white contact lenses and i was thinking
to myself i'm pretty sure and please
correct me if i'm wrong but i'm pretty
sure in 1971 they didn't have like the
soft contacts like they have now they
were hardcore yeah they're usually glass
yeah and all this [ __ ] was a super
expensive special order only hollywood
could get those
because i remember hearing about some
movies like back in the day like hammer
films and stuff like that where you know
somebody had to have red eyes or some
[ __ ]
and they're like yeah they you could
only wear the contacts for like a couple
minutes at a time because they would
just cause your eyes to water because
they were so thick
like they're really really uncomfortable
so i was thinking that that like maybe
they look kind of like modern ones
in this movie but
marilyn manson made them [ __ ] famous
when they hit the soft ones
jesus christ when we went out friday
night was there like he played like
three marilyn manson songs yeah i'm just
like why is why all the marilyn manson i
mean you know what it felt like i guess
i mean it was fun otherwise but i was
just like again with the marilyn manson
i think we covered pretty much
everything on this one um
yeah i think we did like i said i mean
we did this movie this was one of the
first movies that we ever reviewed like
way back probably in 2016.
but because we did last man on earth we
decided that we were gonna do a mega man
so tonight we're gonna watch i am
legends yeah we're gonna watch ambulance
and talk about that because i don't
think we reviewed that i am legend has
uh will smith in it and i want to i saw
it once i want to see the uh the
director's cut they say the director
cuts better and i'm hoping that he slaps
a [ __ ] in it
if he [ __ ] slaps a [ __ ] in the
director's cut i'll be i know what both
endings are yeah um you know what i mean
like i've i haven't seen both endings
but i've seen like a comparison of both
endings like that something we're
talking about i think [ __ ] chris tuck
are gonna make a surprise appearance
neither one of them's like the book
though but like i said i kind of wish
that somebody would just adapt the
[ __ ] book for christ's sake
i mean last man on earth is the closest
last on earth is pretty close
it has a slightly happier ending than
the book i mean the book's ending is
like grim you know what i mean
um
but nobody has really made even though
they've made three adaptations this
nobody has made anything exactly like
the book like with the same themes or
anything like that everybody always like
felt the need to like change stuff up
now richard matheson he didn't really
like he didn't really like last man on
earth he thought it was a little cheap
or whatever this one he didn't really
like this one either but he's like he
didn't really care as much because he's
like this is like so different from my
book that i don't basically don't even
give a [ __ ] you know it's really not
it's it's it's a similar story but it's
not it's very very loose it's a very
loose editor well they didn't want to
have vampires in it yeah
yeah i guess they thought that was like
a little bit too cheesy
cheesy at that time yeah i guess so they
have an explanation of what it was so
they went with mutants yeah
yeah kanavatsan said just the last man
on earth would be a good movie like the
original yeah and like i said just make
it and give it the depressing ending
like the book has like i wish somebody
would have the balls to do that instead
of like always doing a happy ending like
oh we have a vaccine and it saved
everybody in the book it that didn't
happen so i was asking about sunday
night in the live there is no live
podcast on sunday night it's friday well
friday night is the friday wednesday
yes friday it's the side tracks and then
wednesday night it's the main episode
then the rest of the time we just do
movie reviews usually
but yeah we did a show friday night yeah
for a couple hours yeah see this one
again and don't
watch it you know i mean you can't you
can't watch it on the side when you're
working you got to pay attention to it
it's pretty good and uh when i shut it
down we we talked more about it earlier
on in this in this broadcast you
uh brought us this broadcast yeah
all right so yes so tonight we'll be
watching i am legend oh i wanted to say
i don't think oracle is here is she i'm
pretty sure it was oracle
that
recommended on friday night she
recommended the series it's a history
channel series but it's on hulu called
the food that built america
and we watched the first episode last
night and that shit's phenomenal so
thank you for recommending that because
so we're going to watch like the rest of
it it's kind of like the men who built
america about the uh yeah i think it's
the robber barrier yeah i think it's
like the same producers but it's all
about food industry the food guys like
the hot like heinz and hershey and all
she brought that up because the other
day i was talking about how people take
for granted good food that you had to
understand how that came because i
pretty much know the history so it's
just repeating what kind of what i know
but it's a it's a fun watch and there's
some more information in there that i
hadn't considered
but uh now without that corporate
[ __ ] food mass delivery food industry
there wouldn't have been america's you
know it
yeah you had to feed it for it to grow
without that [ __ ] food
without corporate food there would have
been no cities
not big ones yeah because you couldn't
supply them yep yep speaking of food
yeah let's go let's eat
all right so thanks everybody for
dropping by have a good rest of your
weekend and we will see you guys again
tomorrow